so probably no surprise here but the
first thing I wanted to ask you about
was filling the Nick Cage sized hole in
this series when you realize that he
wasn't going to be in the first season
of the show what were some of your
priorities in terms of filling that void
in a sense but also while making sure
you're doing it in a way that's like
organic to the series and suited to your
long-term goals for the show well you
can never replace Nick Cage no matter
what you do he's he's an iconic actor
and unique in everything he does but by
having an ensemble cast that are all
interesting and you can spend time with
your characters because it's a TV show
and it's over a number of episodes where
in National Treasure the movie you can't
it's two hours if the plot's not moving
along the first thing that gets caught
is character so now we have an
opportunity to really get in with these
characters and and find out who they are
and what they're about
um I was also a little curious about I
guess
I get for modern
team and writing teams goals here is for
ensuring that the series will bring in
new fans maybe some younger fans but
then also never lose that kind of
Timeless quality that the original
movies have and also treasure hunting
stories in general have well I think
it's the very similitude of the fact
that all these things are real and live
and it really happened it's
based on history and we love history and
when you could bring it forward and
educate kids
that's that's fantastic absolutely
um I did want to squeeze in one question
about a potential upcoming project
before they make me leave here
um and the one that I I want you have a
million things that I could have focused
on but the one in particular I wanted to
ask about is the Pirates franchise
because I had just read that that story
that the Margot Robbie movie is not
moving forward so it was making me
wonder is there any chance that that
film that script could re-emerge down
the line and if not what do you think is
the next best move for that franchise no
I think that that script will come
forward at a certain point we developed
two different stories for Pirates and
the other ones going forward first
so that's what we're working on to try
to get that one made now is that a cat
behind you that it is yeah this is this
is a real cat this is uh this is my new
baby Malcolm he's named after Jeff
Goldblum in Jurassic Park oh he's doing
he's adorable
thank you thank you he's very
comfortable on cat
great
I'm sure one day
other pet that
'll be speaking of another movie that
you have right now I mean you've
produced your fair share of sequels over
the years but top gun Maverick does feel
to me like it's likely gonna go down in
history as one of the greatest sequels
ever made so is there anything about
your experience making that particular
movie and also seeing the response to it
that might impact your approach to
making sequels and continuing franchises
in the future what just goes to show you
when you make a really good movie
audiences we'll embrace it and that's
what we did we're very fortunate Tom
Cruise is somebody who works so hard and
cares so much and we surrounded him with
terrific people writers and director and
other actors and he worked so hard in
you know the all the flying is real so
it's but it's really about the emotion
it's an emotional story it's about the
characters and emotions I have a very
good feeling we're going to be talking
about that movie for for like ever and
ever but in particular the next couple
of weeks and months I'm putting all the
I'm manifesting it it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen so thank you so we
always talk about like your movies being
like big massive box office spectacle
spectacles and they very much are but
for this National Treasure show in
particular is there any like teeny tiny
detail maybe something that wasn't a big
set piece or even something that isn't
focused on Via a line of dialogue that
that's really struck you about the show
that you just hope that viewers take
notice of a small detail well what I
love is the cast I love
Jess I love all the rest of the cast and
I love the fact that they interact so
well and and their characters are well
defined and they have so much fun doing
it and it's so engaging for an audience
to follow these characters and that's
what we do that's what we try to do spot
on cast chemistry here that's a big
winner
um I must let you go huge
congratulations on this on Top Gun
everything you've accomplished and
everything that you will accomplish you
always keep me coming back for more
thanks Perry and say hello to Malcolm
for me I will when he's done with his
nap he is clearly very excited about
this conversation